to find out how Russia makes tech magic
happen all you have to do is hop on a
flight from Moscow to Siberia
yes that's Siberia it's not just for
gulags anymore
it's hard to wrap your head around how
big Siberia is and even harder to
understand how most people live here so
to get acquainted I found to me tree a
real natural-born Siberian man to
initiate me into the ways of the Russian
wilderness
perfect idea
the trip to the banya is an ancient and
some would say masochistic Russian
bonding ritual it consists of three
delightful steps okay Ashley inferno
either ready fire rings step one nearly
have heatstroke
[Music]
step two
shrinkage step three get whacked
what is this deep silent place when he's
not beating other men with birch
branches my new Russian friend Dmitri is
a philosophy professor here an academic
or a duck that's my destination a small
town hours by plane from Moscow in about
30 minutes outside Russia's third
largest city Novosibirsk
Nikita Khrushchev's government declared
60 years ago that this would be the
Siberian home of the Soviet Academy of
Sciences built from nothing in the
middle of a remote taiga forest that
stretches halfway around the planet
academic or a dacha it was the first
Soviet techno police and it was a good
opportunity for many young scientists
how's it changed over the last what it
is in comparison to Soviet time we have
not so much opportunities but we love
our place because it's wonderful 40
institutes a real scientific community
shelters Oh what was the no Beauty to
the enemies of science so swatted
steaming and having proven my loyalty to
science I was ready to explore academic
or a dog
[Music]
here the Soviets hid temples the science
in the trees with shrines to match like
this one to all the mice they sacrificed
on the altar of genetic research inside
the nuclear physics Institute it feels
like I walked onto the set of dr.
Strangelove these analog dials Laser
contraptions and miles of metal pipes
we're all built to push nuclear science
to its summit replicating the sun's
power by smashing atoms together people
have been chasing fusion for decades
what's still encouraging and exciting
about this field the scientific problem
is like a huge mountain and for 60 years
people are trying to get to the top
everything around the base of the
mountain is like trash dump as a result
bodies stuff but you can imagine the
results you can achieve when you get to
the top
professor alexei beck Lumi chef's
research is something called open trap
mechanisms to encourage fusion in theory
is a shortcut to the top of the mountain
with a smaller load this is also useful
in order to make plasma thrusters for
space ships so you can use this to power
a spaceship going to Mars yeah at the
moment it is just an idea it means a lot
of refinement so this is more of like a
2080
sort of thing yeah
the Soviet government attracted
brilliant minds like Alexis to Siberia
with spacious apartments in the kind of
prestige they could only get in a town
founded as a utopian nur da cracy but
when the Soviet Union fell so did the
walls keeping scientists here and many
of them bolted to work at IBM where MIT
or Boeing for those who stayed the
Utopia has lost its luster over time the
difference in pay between scientists and
say bus drivers event in favor of both
drivers if you are overworked and
without pay you you want to go elsewhere
ten years ago the Russian government
decided it needed to hit refresh on the
entire town to pull Siberian science out
of its post-soviet slump they're turning
to a new generation of engineers plucked
from the taiga to lead the way and one
of the most successful so far is Dmitri
true Beatson today academic RDoc is
changing now there are not only
scientists but there are also a lot of
companies where like startup yeah more
like startups Dimitri's company Tionne
started off making king-size air filters
for hospitals and other businesses as
far as starting a company here you
didn't think now that I have this idea
I'm going to run off it's a Silicon
Valley you decided this is the spot
where you would give it a go well it's
very comfortable place and the right a
lot of for good smart people here also
have where fresh air here and it's very
useful - yeah it's very useful for our
company because we can we can compare
the air we produce with the cleanest air
in the world
today Dimitri is the poster boy for a
Siberian startup success story and he
feels like his close to the finish line
on phase one of his vision Phase two
takes him to China where his company is
rapidly expanding there he hopes to get
his devices out of hospitals and into
homes with this little guy that detects
pollutants in the air just blow over the
top a dozen my prism like co2 he'll fill
it that's enough
look it goes down so the lights are
going down yeah it means that Airport is
not very good now it tried to increase
the speed of fan in breeze run this room
to lower the concentration of carbon
dioxide cool it seems to work Dimitri is
not a wholly self-made man tea on
success belongs to him but it's built on
a blueprint drawn up by the Russian
government his headquarters is on a
sprawling government funded campus
called academic with this crazy tower in
the middle of it not recommended if you
have a fear of heights
this place is a prime example of one of
the big ideas in Russian tank a
cradle-to-grave genius factory across
the country they start them young with a
strictly uniform education heavy on math
and science they pull the best out of
Siberia and send them down the street to
Novosibirsk State University from there
they used to funnel their brains to
places like the Nuclear Institute but
now that that's a bit retro many of them
end up here in the tech tower here it's
like someone visited a few Silicon
Valley startups punch the copy button
ran it through Google Translate and then
hit paste in the middle of Siberia
here's the living wall only here it's
dead here's the makerspace and the 3d
printed Putin here's the gym only it's
Siberia so it comes with bear
hello innovation case in point
my new friend Kirill where are you from
originally I was born here in the Korean
car look who's your father mother
engineers as we are yeah they graduated
from no Smith State University and they
was a computer engineer Soviet computer
engineer is big computers okay you can
tell by the Terminator looking device on
the table the Kirill makes drones
he says his drone is special because it
can take off vertically and then fly
very very far very very fast Kirill
season op 2 plane drone flying miles
along high-tension power lines
checking for brakes presuming to the
side of forest fires and floods across
Siberia a team of engineers barely out
of high school and most definitely still
in college built this carbon-fiber
prototype by hand in four months it's
quite a challenge to start John startup
in Russia because of low constraints
because of investment climate traditions
of mind of our clients is not so easy to
break this is in a sort of radical yeah
it's kind of radical our technology
so this drone company started in a
Russian government-funded incubator is
too radical for its clients who maybe
you guessed it or part of the Russian
government op two planes first contract
came from the Russian version of FEMA
and it built this first prototype with
money from a government backed venture
capital firm they wouldn't exist without
the government and they barely exist
because of it
Russia is very centralized country so
the United States for example with state
laws is faster than in Russia you have
to get exceptions to test your drones
and fly them around here and that's
difficult to do yeah yeah so are there
many drone companies in Russia not so
many then in America
it looks really cool it looks good yeah
like Skynet is awesome idea it's through
the sheer force of their engineering
smarts and passion that Optive plane has
gotten off the ground out here in
Siberia they're part of one grand
experiment in state-supported innovation
we'll have to see what the next 60 years
bring to this silicon forest
[Music]